- 「量子情報と計算の理解」へ
ようこそ。
私はJohn Watrousで、
IBM Quantum Educationのテクニカルディレクターだ。
これはシリーズの第6レッスンで、量子アルゴリズムを扱う
シリーズ第2ユニットの第2レッスンだ。
前回のレッスンでは計算のクエリモデルについて議論し、
そのモデルでは量子アルゴリズムが
驚くべき優位性を持てることを見た。
Simonの問題の場合における指数的な優位性を含め、
古典アルゴリズムに対して圧倒的に優れている。
残念ながら、クエリモデルは
直接的または即座の実用的な
関連性をあまり持っていない。
ブラックボックスという概念は非常に有用な
抽象化だとわかっているが、
応用するためにはいくつかの作業が必要だ。
クエリモデルから得られた洞察を、入力がビット列として与えられる
より標準的な計算設定に
適用するためには。
オラクルやブラックボックスとしてではなく。
このレッスンの主な目的は、
それを実現するための基盤を確立することだ。
レッスンの概要はこうだ。レッスンの大部分は
計算コストに焦点を当てる。
つまり、さまざまな計算タスクがどれほど難しいか、
その難しさをどう測れるかということだ。
大まかに言えば、これは計算が終わるまで
どれだけ待たなければならないか、
そして最終的にどの計算問題を
解けるか、そしてどれが
手の届かないところにあるかに繋がる。
まずいくつかの例から始める。
整数の素因数分解と
最大公約数（GCD）の計算だ。
これらは基本原理を説明するのに非常に良い例であり、
どちらも次のレッスンで議論する
Shorのアルゴリズムに深く関連している。
だから、これらの例から
二重の効果が得られるわけだ。
次に、計算コストという概念をより一般的に議論し、
それをどう測るかを扱う。
これにはさまざまな方法があるが、
計算のcircuitモデルを使ってどう行うかに
かなり絞って焦点を当てる。
具体的にはブールcircuitと
量子circuitだ。
ここでの焦点は、例えばコンピュータのハードウェアではなく、
アルゴリズムに置かれる。また、
アルゴリズムを実行する際のコストが、
それが実行される特定の問題インスタンスのサイズが大きくなるにつれて
どのようにスケールするかに関心がある。
何秒、
何分、あるいは何時間かかるかといった
特定の計算の話ではなく。
この観点を動機づけるアイデアは、
アルゴリズムが根本的な重要性を持つということだ。
今日に至るまで、はるか昔に開発された
アルゴリズムを依然として使い続けている。
そして当然のことながら、それらは
技術が発展するにつれて、より速く信頼性の高い
ハードウェアを使って、より大きな
問題インスタンスに対して展開されることになる。
そしてそれらがどのようにスケールするかは、
それらがどれほど有用であり、これからも有用であり続けるかについて
多くを語っている。
レッスンの最後のセクションでは、
非常に重要なタスクに目を向ける。
それは量子コンピュータ上での古典計算の実行だ。
これが重要な理由は、古典コンピュータを
量子コンピュータで置き換えることを期待しているからではない。
それが実現するとしても近い将来ではないし、
実現しないかもしれない。そうではなく、
これが多くの興味深い可能性を
量子アルゴリズムに
開くからだ。
具体的には、量子コンピュータ上で古典計算を実行する方法がわかれば、
それらがサブルーティンとして
量子アルゴリズムで利用可能になる。
そうすれば実質的に、量子計算上の優位性を追求する中で
古典アルゴリズムについて知っていることすべてを
活用できるわけだ。
今日の古典コンピュータは本当に
テクノロジーの驚異だ。
信じられないほど速いが、
どんな計算問題でも解けるほど
速いわけではない。
一部の計算問題はそれ自体が非常に難しく、
それを解くアルゴリズムは存在するものの、
今日の地球上のどのコンピュータも
人間の一生のうちに、中程度のサイズの入力でさえ
これらのアルゴリズムを最後まで実行するには
速度が足りない。
地球そのものの寿命の中でさえ
そうかもしれない。
さらに説明するために、
整数の素因数分解問題を
見てみよう。
問題の記述は非常にシンプルだ。問題への入力は2以上の整数Nで、
出力はNの
素因数分解だ。
それが意味するのは、Nの素数因子のリストと、
それらの素数を何乗すればよいかを合わせたものだ。
それらをすべて掛け合わせることで
Nが得られるように。
もちろん、素因数はどんな順序で掛け合わせてもよいが、
順序を除けば、
素因数分解はNの選択すべてに対して
常に一意だ。
その事実は算術の基本定理と呼ばれており、
それについてもっと知りたければ、
数論に関する多くの本の
冒頭で見つけられる。
非常に簡単な例として、
12という数の素因数分解を示そう。
2の2乗掛ける
3の1乗だ。
当然ながら、コンピュータは
素因数を繰り返し探索するだけで
瞬時にこれを教えてくれる。
もう一つ例を挙げよう。この数を読もうとは思わない。
約3.4クアトゥオルデシリオンで、そんな名前があること自体
奇妙だと正直思うが、
とにかく、46桁の10進数で、
ここにその素因数分解が見える。
コンピュータもこれを教えてくれる。この数はPythonの
記号数学ライブラリに含まれる因数分解法を使って因数分解した。
数秒かかったが、特に長い時間ではない。
ただ、明らかな遅延はあった。
factor N法は確かに、素因数を
単純に探索することでこの素因数分解を求めているわけではない。
実際には、colored row algorithmと呼ばれるものを含む
異なるアルゴリズムのハイブリッドを使っている。これは因数分解のためのアルゴリズムで、
素因数を繰り返し単純に探索するよりも
洗練されている。そしてかなり大きな数に
見えるかもしれないが、
計算問題への入力としては、実際にはそれほど
大きくない。
わずか46文字だ。
もう一つ例を挙げよう。309桁の10進数だ。
2進数表記で書くと1,024ビットになる。
だからRSA1024と呼ばれている。
この数の素因数分解は現在知られていない。
この数はRSA因数分解チャレンジから来ている。
RSA Laboratoriesが1991年から2007年にかけて
実施したものだ。
さまざまな大きさの数の素因数分解に対して
賞金を提供していた。これもその一つで、
10万米ドルの価値があった。
しかしその賞金は受け取られることはなかった。
RSA公開鍵暗号システムのセキュリティは
整数の因数分解の難しさに基づいている。
因数分解できれば
システムを破れる。だからチャレンジの目的は
基本的に因数分解の最先端を追跡することだった。
結論としては、この数を因数分解することは
現在の能力を超えている。
知る限り、この問題は古典的なコンピュータが
実際に解くには複雑すぎる。
ちなみに、これまでに因数分解された最大の
RSAチャレンジ数は250桁だ。
画面で読みにくいかもしれないが、
これがRSA250の素因数分解だ。
2020年にnumber field sieveとして知られる
アルゴリズムを使って行われた。世界中の数万台の
コンピュータが関わった集団的な取り組みだった。
では、別の計算問題を考えてみよう。
最大公約数、略してGCDを計算する
問題だ。
二つの非負整数のGCDだ。
問題の説明はこうだ。今回は入力が
二つの数、NとMで構成される。
そして二つとも
ゼロではないと仮定する。
目標はこの二数のGCDを計算することだ。
NとMの両方を割り切れる最大の整数Dのことだ。
NとMの素因数分解について考えると、
GCDはNとMの両方を割り切る
素数すべての積だとわかる。
二つの素因数分解に現れる冪の最小値まで
NとMの両方を割り切るものだ。
つまり整数の因数分解の問題と
関連しているが、はるかに、
はるかに簡単だとわかる。
コンピュータにとって解くのが容易だ。何千桁もある数のGCDを
瞬時に計算できる。
画面で例を見せようとしても無意味だ。
画面を数字で埋め尽くしても
まだ説明し続けることになる。
この問題の簡単に解けるインスタンスを。
でも興味があれば、動画の説明にある
このレッスンの教科書ページへのリンクを辿ると
コードセルが見つかる。
話しているような種類の計算の、
大きな数のGCDを計算するものも含め、
自分で試すことができる。
問題は、なぜGCDをこれほど簡単に
計算できるのかということだ。
その答えは、GCDを計算する
効率的なアルゴリズムがあるからだ。
その中にはEuclidのアルゴリズムがある。
2,000年以上前に発見されたが、
他にも効率的なGCDアルゴリズムがある。
もちろんここで話しているのは古典的なアルゴリズムだから、
別の疑問が生じる。
整数の因数分解に対して
効率的な古典的アルゴリズムが存在し、
RSA1024のような数を瞬時に
因数分解できるのだろうか？
答えはイエスだ。因数分解のための
効率的な古典的アルゴリズムは絶対に
ありうる。現時点では
その可能性を排除する方法がわかっていない。
言えることは、まだ見つかっていないということだけだ。
知っているすべての古典的な
因数分解アルゴリズムについて言えば、
本質的にはまだ因数を探している。
そのためRSA1024のような数は
手の届かないところにある。
一方で効率的なGCDアルゴリズムは
そういう動き方をしない。
最大公約数を探索するのではなく、
機械的な手順でそれを
実質的に構築する。コストは大まかに
同じ二数を掛け合わせるのと
同程度で、これについてはレッスンの後半で
もう少し詳しく述べる。
もちろん、これは全部Shorのアルゴリズムへの布石で、次のレッスンで見ていくが、効率的な量子アルゴリズムだ
素因数分解を計算するためのものだが、そこに辿り着く前にまだカバーすべき内容がある。
次は、異なるアルゴリズムの計算コストを測定できる数学的なフレームワークについて話す。
これにはすでに話したアルゴリズムも含まれる。
はっきり言っておくと、ここではcircuitに非常に狭く焦点を当てるつもりで、それははるかに広い分野のほんの一部に過ぎない。
前のレッスンの通常の計算を非常に高いレベルの視点から始めよう。つまり特に、クエリ問題については考えない。
入力がバイナリ文字列として明示的に与えられる問題について考える。
前のレッスンで言ったように、望めば他の記号も使えるが、シンプルにしてバイナリ文字列だけにしておこう。
入力にも出力にもバイナリ文字列を使う。
計算そのものは、Turingマシンの計算モデルのような様々な方法でモデル化または記述できる。
Booleanのcircuitやquantumのcircuitのほか、PythonやあなたがZ選んだ他の言語で書かれたプログラムでも記述できる。
さっき言ったように、Booleanとquantumのcircuitに集中するつもりだ。
まず、入力と出力についてもう少し時間をかけて話そう。これらはバイナリ文字列だと仮定している。
バイナリ文字列を使って、数、ベクトル、行列、グラフなど多くの異なる種類の数学的対象をエンコードできる。
例えば分子の記述や、これらのオブジェクトのリスト、その他のものもエンコードできる。
非常にシンプルな例として、非負整数をバイナリ文字列としてエンコードしたい場合、二進法が使える。
このテーブルには最初の13個の非負整数と、それらの二進数表現またはエンコーディングが表示されている。
3列目では、これらの各エンコーディングの長さが見られる。これはエンコーディングに必要なビットの総数だ。
そしてここに、任意の非負整数Nに対して一般的に何ビット必要かを正確に教えてくれるシンプルな公式がある。
特に注目してほしいのは、エンコーディングの長さは一般的に数そのものよりもはるかに小さいということだ。
数の対数になっている。
例えばRSA1024は長さ1,024のエンコーディングを持つが、数そのものはもちろんそれよりもはるかに大きい。
このエンコーディングスキームは非負整数には機能するが、負の整数を含む任意の整数を扱いたい場合は、符号ビットを単に付け加えればいい。
エンコーディングを固定サイズのビットブロックまたはレジスタで埋めたい場合は、これらのエンコーディングで先頭にいくつでもゼロを許可することもできる。
十分な大きさであれば。それが非常に便利な場合もある。
これが整数をビット列としてエンコードする唯一の方法ではない。
他の方法もあるが、これはかなり標準的な方法だ。
興味のある計算問題への入力または出力を形成するかもしれない他の種類のオブジェクトに対しては、他のエンコーディングスキームを考え出せる。
例えば、ベクトルやグラフをバイナリ文字列としてエンコードする方法を考えてみよう。あるいは、どうやって
2つのバイナリ文字列を、スペースや他の記号を使わずにゼロと1の記号だけで1つのバイナリ文字列にエンコードするかを考えてみよう。
2つの文字列を区切る方法がある。確かにそういう方法はあり、実際どうやるかについてはかなり自由度がある。
話しているものをバイナリ文字列としてエンコードするための単一の標準や普遍的に合意された方法がないことが多い。
でもそれで大丈夫だ。一つを選ぶか、好みなら新しいものを発明すればいい。
純粋に形式的な観点から見ると、計算というのは基本的にビット列に対する機械的な変換として考えている。
使用するエンコーディングスキームの具体的な内容は、あるレベルでは確かに重要だ。
しかし、アルゴリズムを設計・分析するとき、通常エンコーディングスキームの具体的な内容をそれほど気にしない。
例えば、特定の種類の分子をバイナリ文字列としてエンコードする方法を2人の異なる人に考えてもらうとしよう。
彼らが異なる方法を考え出すかもしれないが、もし彼らが何をしているか分かっている合理的な人たちなら、
2つのエンコーディングスキーム間で行き来する変換がかなりシンプルな計算プロセスであることも合理的に期待できる。
おそらく、興味ある実際の計算と比べてかなり簡単な、非常に単純な計算が必要なだけだろう。
結論は、使用するエンコーディングスキームの詳細はしばしば二次的であり、焦点はアルゴリズムそのものにあるということだ。
ところで、このレッスンではこれは問題にならない。主に整数に関する問題に焦点を当てていて、それらはバイナリでエンコードされていると仮定する。
でも、知っておくべきことだ。
一般的に、どんな種類の問題について話していても、入力長とは入力をエンコードするために必要なビット数のことを指す。
そして、考えている問題のインスタンスのサイズとして入力長を捉える。
では、計算そのものを考えよう。この図の青い長方形で表されている。
この計算のコストを測定する方法は、必要な基本演算の数を数えることだ。
直感的に言えば、基本演算とは少数の固定されたビットまたはqubitを含む演算だ。
例えば2つのビットのANDを計算するなど、素早く簡単に実行できるものだ。
形式的なレベルでは、
基本演算とは何かを定義する方法はいくつかあって、どの
計算モデルを使うかによって異なる。
例えば、チューリング機械を使うモデルなら、基本演算はチューリング機械の1ステップになる。
このレッスンの目的上、すでに述べたように circuit モデル、特に量子
と Boolean circuit に焦点を当てる。
circuit を扱うとき、各 gate が基本演算を表すと考えるのが一般的だ。
このシリーズでは、これまでにいくつかの異なる量子 gate を見てきた。
X、Y、Z gate、Hadamard gate、S gate、T gate などだ。
controlled NOT gate、swap gate、Toffoli gate、Fredkin gate も含まれる。
また、query モデルの文脈で query gate についても話したが、このレッスンでは query モデルの中では作業しないので、
query gate については今は気にしなくていい。
さらに、任意の数の qubit に対する任意のユニタリ演算は、
望むなら gate として見なせることも分かった。
ただし、コストを測る目的では、それはあまり役に立たないので、やることはシンプルに
gate の集合を選ぶことだ。
そしてその集合を基本演算の集合と見なす。
まず、ここに示す
1 qubit のユニタリ gate を含める。
すなわち X、Y、Z gate だ。
Hadamard gate、S gate、T gate、およびそれらの逆行列
つまり共役転置も含める。
実際にはこれらの gate がすべて必要なわけじゃない。Hadamard と T gate があれば残りは実装できる。
ただ、便宜上すべてを含めることにする。
controlled NOT gate も含める。これが集合の中で唯一の
複数 qubit gate になる。
そして最後に、1 qubit の標準基底測定を含める。これにより、
circuit から古典情報を
実際に取り出せるようになる。
ユニタリ gate だけに注目して測定のことを
一旦忘れると、いわゆる
ユニバーサル gate セットが得られる。
それが意味するのは、
任意の数の qubit に対する任意のユニタリ演算が
完全に実装できるか
あるいは任意に近い精度で、
これらの gate だけで構成された quantum circuit で実現できるということだ。
言い換えれば、これは
任意のユニタリ演算を構築できる十分な
gate の集合だ。
必ずしも完全にではないが、望む精度の
近似を得ることができる。
それには多くの gate が必要になることもあって、実際、場合によっては多くの gate が
必要だと推論するのはそれほど難しくない。
それでも、常に可能だ。
ただ、これがユニバーサル gate セットであることを証明するのは簡単じゃなく、
シリーズではその方法は扱わない。
でも、これはかなりよく知られた事実で、実際に証明できる
方法は複数ある。
また、測定に加えて Toffoli gate、Hadamard gate、S gate など、
この代わりに使われる gate セットも他にある。
ただ、これはかなり標準的な選択だ。
まとめると、これらが
基本的と見なす量子演算だ。
Boolean circuit については、
AND gate、OR gate、NOT gate、FANOUT の
4つの gate を基本演算と考える。
ちなみに FANOUT は、
必ずしも gate として数えられるわけじゃないが、
レッスンの後半で見るように、これを含めることが重要になる。
標準的な量子 gate セットの場合と同様に、この集合は少し冗長だ。
AND と OR の両方は必要ない。NOT gate を3つ使えば、どちらか一方でもう一方を作れる。
でも、両方含めても問題ないし、便利でもある。
すでに知っているかもしれないが、これは
決定論的計算に対するユニバーサル gate セットで、つまりビットからビットへの任意の関数は
この集合の gate で構成された Boolean circuit で実装できる。
再び、quantum circuit の場合と同じように、これはすべての関数が Boolean circuit で効率的に実装できるという意味じゃない。
実際、ほとんどの関数は
非常に大きな circuit でしか実装できない。
その単純な理由は、関数がたくさんたくさんあるからで
それらすべてが小さな circuit を持てるわけじゃない。単に小さな circuit の数が足りないんだ。
ユニバーサル性は、量子の場合に比べて、
この場合のほうが証明しやすいことが分かっている。
もし証明方法をまだ知らないなら、少し考えてみて、
興味があれば自分で解けるか試してみてほしい。
使う gate と基本演算と見なす gate を決めたので、それらがいくつ
必要かを考えることができる。
様々な計算を
実行するためにだ。
そのために、
circuit のサイズのこの定義を利用する。
この定義は Boolean と quantum circuit の両方に使えて、非常にシンプルだ。
circuit のサイズとは
それが持つ gate の総数だ。
例えば、これまで何度も見てきたのと同じ例、
つまり2ビットの排他的論理和を計算する Boolean circuit に戻ると、
サイズは7だと分かる。
なぜなら gate が7つあるからで、FANOUT gate が2つ、NOT gate が2つ、
AND gate が2つ、OR gate が1つ。もし
FANOUT gate を数えないことにすれば（これはよくあることだが）、サイズは5になる。
でも FANOUT gate を数えるので、サイズは7だ。
circuitのサイズは、
実行する必要がある基本演算の数に
対応している。
それらの演算を順番に実行するとしたら、
サイズはどれくらいかかるかを
教えてくれることになる。
つまり、circuit のサイズは
逐次実行時間を表すと考えられる。
これが、このレッスンにおける
計算コストの測り方になる。
ただ、circuitには別の特性もあって、
それもcircuitの実行に必要な時間として
見ることができる。それがcircuitの深さだ。
正確に言うと、深さとは
入力ワイヤから出力ワイヤへの任意のパスで
通過するgateの最大数のことだ。
これはcircuitを作るために必要な
gateの層の数と同じで、
層とは一群のgateを指す。
共通のワイヤを持たないため
同時に実行できるgateたちのことだ。
例えば、さっきのcircuitは深さ4で、
図を見れば直接、4層あることが
わかる。
FANOUTのgateは同時に実行でき、
NOTのgateも同時に実行でき、
ANDのgateも同時に実行できる。
だから、circuit の深さは
並列実行時間を表すと考えられる。
circuit の深さは確かに興味深く重要な概念で、
深さを削減するために使える
非常に洗練された技術もある。
一部の計算に必要な深さは、
場合によってはかなり劇的に削減できるが、
それは高度なトピックだ。
このシリーズではこれ以上
あまり触れるつもりはない。
というわけで改めて、計算コストは
circuitのサイズ、つまり言い換えれば、
ある計算を実行するために必要な
基本演算の数で測ることにする。
レッスンの冒頭で、整数の因数分解問題について
話し、この問題を解くアルゴリズムに
必要な時間が
入力が長くなるにつれて増加することを見た。
これが通常、私たちが注目する
ポイントだ。
アルゴリズムを分析するときにね。
つまり、入力がどんどん大きくなるにつれて
アルゴリズムの実行コストがどのようにスケールするか、
それに興味があるわけだ。
もちろん、こういったスケーリングだけが
重要なわけじゃない。
例えば、RSA1024の因数を
単純に求めたいだけ、
ということもある。
そういうケースでは、
何も成長しない単一の問題インスタンスを
扱っていることになる。
だが、アルゴリズムについて考えるとき、
コストのスケールの仕方は非常に重要で、
アルゴリズムについて多くのことを教えてくれる。
この視点は、アルゴリズムが根本的なものだという
考え方と一致している。さっきも話したように、
時間が経ち技術が進歩するにつれて、
アルゴリズムはより大きな入力に対して
使われるようになっていく。
ただ、計算問題への入力はサイズが
大きくなれるが、circuitは大きくならないことに
注意してほしい。
各circuitは固定サイズを持つ。
だから、circuitを使ってアルゴリズムを
記述したいなら、実際にはcircuitのファミリーが
必要になる。
circuitのファミリーとは、入力に対応できるよう
どんどん大きくなっていく
circuitのコレクションを意味する。
入力がどんどん大きくなるのに対応するためだ。
例えば、古典的な決定論的アルゴリズムを
考えてみよう。
整数因数分解問題のためのもので、
試し割りに基づいたものかもしれないが、
この例では具体的な中身はあまり重要じゃない。
この例の目的にはね。
原理的には、そういうアルゴリズムを
ブール circuitのファミリーを使って記述できる。
ある数を因数分解したい場合、
Nビットの2進数表現を持つ数なら、
ファミリーからcircuit CNを取り出して、
因数分解したい数を
そのcircuitの入力ビットに入力する。
これらのcircuitを異なる方法で
パラメータ化することもある。
N番目のcircuitが必ずN個の入力ビットを
持つとは限らない場合もある。
でも、それがかなり典型的なやり方だ。
当然、入力長が長くなるにつれて、
このファミリーのcircuitはより大きくなると
予想される。4ビットの数を因数分解する方が
1024ビットの数を因数分解するより
はるかに簡単だという事実を反映してね。
そういった点を踏まえて、そういった
アルゴリズムのコストを関数で測る。
その関数は、各入力長に対して何個の
基本演算が必要かを教えてくれる。
これは古典アルゴリズムにも量子アルゴリズムにも使える。
例として、整数の加算問題を
考えてみよう。因数分解よりも
はるかにシンプルな問題だ。
GCDを計算するよりもね。
シンプルに保つために、NとMは
両方とも非負整数で、
表現されているとしよう。
同じ長さの2進数文字列でね。
この2つの数を足し合わせる
ブール circuitをどう作ればいいだろうか？
まず、加算の標準的なアルゴリズムから
始めよう。これは、私たちが習った方法の
2進数版だ。
鉛筆と紙で数を足す方法を
みんな習ったと思うが、
最下位ビットから始めて、
足し合わせる。そうすると結果の最下位ビットと、
次の位置に進むときに考慮しなければならない
キャリービットが得られる。
次のビット位置に進み続け、
キャリービットとともに
出力ビットを生成していく。
最後まで来るまでね。
この方法はBoolean circuitの観点から
かなり直接的に表現できる。
考え方の一つとして、1ビット整数二つを足し合わせる小さなcircuitから始めるやり方がある。
それで0から2の間の数が得られ、
下位ビットは入力ビットのXOR、
上位ビット、つまり好みによってはキャリービットは、
二つの入力ビットのANDだ。
この二つの演算をまとめて行うcircuitを
ハーフアダーと呼ぶことがある。
入力ビットが二つだけなら問題ないが、
1ビット以上の整数を足し合わせたい場合は、
キャリービットを
何とか処理する必要がある。
そこでできることは、ハーフアダーを二つカスケード接続して、
それぞれが生成するキャリービットのORを取り、
フルアダーと呼ばれるものを作ることだ。
フルアダーは基本的に、1ビット数三つを
足し合わせるためのBoolean circuitだ。
フルアダーさえあれば、最下位ビットから始めて
カスケード接続していくだけで数を足し合わせられる。
最上位ビットへと進んでいく。基本的には
フルアダーを使ってキャリービットを処理しながら
標準的な加算アルゴリズムを実装しているだけだ。
では、この計算のコストはどのくらいか？
各XOR gateに7つの基本的なgateが必要で、
つまりハーフアダーには10個のgateが必要になる。
したがってフルアダーには21個のgateが必要で、
これはハーフアダー二つとOR gate一つだ。
結局のところ、入力数がどちらもNビットなら、
最下位ビット用にハーフアダーが一つ必要で、
残りの各ビットにはフルアダーが必要で、
最終的には21×(N-1)+10、つまり合計21N-11個のgateが必要だ。
何らかの理由でFANOUT gateを
数えたくないと判断し、XOR gateを
gate集合に含めるなら、合計で
5N-3個のgateが必要になる。
さまざまな計算を行うのに必要なgateや
基本演算の数を正確に把握できるのは便利だ。
整数加算で今見たようなものがその例だ。
もちろん、これらの計算を実際に実装したいなら、
そういった詳細を知る必要がある。
しかし、特により複雑なアルゴリズムで
いつもここまで詳細に踏み込んでいたら、
あっという間に詳細の山に埋もれてしまう。
多くの場合、その詳細は
二次的な重要性しか持たない。
アルゴリズムの解析でよく使われる
簡略化の方法の一つが、ビッグO記法の活用だ。
これによって成長率を
かなり簡単に表現・比較できるようになり、
非常に便利だ。
この記法の根底にある定義をここで確認できる。
二つの関数GとHがあるとしよう。
簡単のため、非負整数の値を取ると考えていい。
実際にはそれは必須ではないが。
例えばGとHはそれぞれ異なる計算のコストを表しているとしよう。
そのとき、GはHのビッグOだと言う。
これは伝統的にこのように等号で書く。
Nが十分大きい限り、G(N)がある正の定数C倍のH(N)以下であれば。
つまりこれはNが大きくなったときに
何が起きるかについての話だ。
形式的には、「十分大きい」とは、
N₀という選択があって、その不等式が成立するという意味だ。
NがN₀以上のときはいつでも。
ここで重要なのは、
CとN₀という数が固定されていることだ。
どんな数でも構わないが、何であれ
Nが大きくなっても変わってはいけない。
こういった定義を見たことがないなら、
慣れるまで時間がかかるかもしれないし、
この概念を説明するリソースも見つかるはずだ。
このレッスンで説明できる以上の
詳細が書かれたものが。
通常は、関数Gがどれくらい速く成長するかについて
何かを表現するために、Hをシンプルな関数として選ぶ。
例えば、17N³-257という値を持つ関数は、
N²×65537がN³のビッグOであり、
定義にこの例を当てはめることができる。
CとN₀を適切に選ぶことで。
例えばCを18とすれば、
Nが十分大きい限り、その式は
確かに18N³以下になる。
この記法を整数加算の例に結びつけると、
今言えるのは、Boolean circuitのファミリーが存在するということだ。
非負整数を加算するためのもので、
N番目のcircuitのサイズ、つまり長さNの入力に対して動作するものは、
N のビッグOだ。分析によると
circuitの実際のサイズは21N-11だが、
それはNのビッグOだ。
こうして詳細を捨てることが
常に賢明というわけではないが、ここでは理にかなっている。
なぜなら、標準的な加算アルゴリズムの本質的な性質、
つまりコストが線形にスケールするという事実が見えてくるからだ。
足し合わせる数のサイズに対して線形で、
この表現はモデルの低レベルな詳細の一部に
依存しないからだ。
例えば、どのgateを基本演算とみなすかといった
詳細には影響されない。
例えば、XOR gateを基本演算とみなすべきとか、
FANOUT gateはgateとして数えないとか、
あるいはその両方と決めても、
整数加算はNのビッグOのコストで
計算できるという結論は変わらない。
計算問題のもう一つの例として、
整数の乗算を取り上げよう。
加算と同様に、この計算の
コストはいくらかと問うことができる。
標準的な乗算アルゴリズム、つまり
小学校で教わる数の掛け算の
2進数版について考えると、
2進数で扱う場合は基本的に
シフトと加算だけで済み、
N二乗のbig-OサイズのBoolean circuitが存在することがわかる。
これはNビット整数の乗算のためのものだ。
ここでは詳細には踏み込まない。もちろん
circuitは加算のものより少し複雑だが、
やり方を考えると
標準的な乗算アルゴリズムの
仕組みから考えれば、驚くことではない。
本質的には、おおよそN回の加算が必要で、
それぞれが線形コストを持つため、
全体として二次コストになる。
これは一般化できる。一方の数がNビットで
もう一方がMビットなら、big-O of N times Mサイズの
circuitが必要だ。
ここで、複数の変数を持つbig-O表記の
拡張を実際に使っているが、
このように拡張することができる。
具体的な詳細に興味があれば、
この授業の教科書コンテンツを参照してほしい。
動画の説明欄にリンクがある。
実は、標準的な乗算アルゴリズムより
漸近的に優れた方法で
2つのNビット整数を掛け合わせることが可能だ。
特に、Schonhage-Strassen乗算アルゴリズムは
2つのNビット整数をbig-O of N times the length of Nの
コストで乗算する。
times the length of the length of N。つまりNが
数万ビットのように大きくなると、
これは実際により効率的な乗算方法だが、
複雑であり、オーバーヘッドのせいで
小さい数には実用的でない。
では、乗算を例のリストに追加しよう。
簡単のため、標準的な乗算アルゴリズムで
与えられるコスト、つまりbig-O of N二乗を載せよう。
改めて、このコストの本質的な性質に
着目しよう。それは二次的にスケールするということだ。
あるいは漸近的に優れた方法を使えば
二次未満にもなる。
整数除算の問題も考えられる。
画面に正確に示されている。
ここでは商と余りを計算するので、
答えはQとRという2つの整数から成る。
こちらも標準的な除算アルゴリズムがあり、
二次コストを持つ。乗算と同様に、
漸近的に優れたアルゴリズムが
実際に存在する。
では、GCDアルゴリズムはどう比較されるだろうか？
ユークリッドのアルゴリズムは
二次コストを持つことがわかっていて、
授業の前半で言ったのはそのことで、
GCDの計算は
2つの数を掛け合わせるのと
おおよそ同じコストでできると言った。
こちらも、加算や乗算と同様の
漸近的に優れたアルゴリズムが存在する。
ただし、少なくとも現時点でわかる限りでは、
このケースではコストが少し高い。
このリストに加えるもう一つの問題の例として、
モジュラー指数計算を挙げよう。
入力数はK、M、Nの3つで、
目標はNのK乗のmodulo-Mを
計算することだ。
つまりMで割った後の
余りということだ。
全く明らかではないが、モジュラー指数計算を
qubitコスト、つまりNビット整数に対して
big-O of N三乗で計算できる。
これを行う方法は、まずNのK乗を計算してから
余りを計算するのではない。
NのK乗を書き下すだけでも
指数的なビット数が必要になる可能性があるため、
そのアプローチは機能しない。
代わりに、べき乗アルゴリズムと呼ばれる、
繰り返し二乗法とも呼ばれるアルゴリズムを使える。
全てmodulo-Mで行う。
Kのビットを使って反復的に
二乗と乗算を行い、
うまくいくようにする。
これは他のものより高コストだが、
数千ビットの数でも
モジュラー指数計算をかなり速く実行できる。
では、これらのタスクのコストは
整数因数分解と比べてどうだろうか？
シンプルに考えて、試し割り法から始めると、
まず2が入力数の因数かどうかを確認し、
次に3を確認し、という具合に進むと、
かなり高コストなアルゴリズムになる。
big-O of N二乗 times 2のN/2乗だ。
各除算は二次時間かかり、最悪の場合、
入力数の平方根まで素因数を
探す必要がある。
N over twoはそこから来ている。その時点で
素因数が見つかっていなければ、
止めることができる。なぜなら
入力数自体が素数に違いないからだ。
これは非常に高コストだ。なぜならNがこの式の
指数として現れているからで、
つまりこのアルゴリズムは指数的コストを持つ。
対照的に、このボックス内の全ての例は
多項式コストと呼ばれるものを持ち、
Nがある冪乗に上げられるが、
その冪乗は常に固定された数で、
入力の長さが増えても
増加しない。
これらのケースでは、
冪乗は1、2、3だ。
多項式コスト対指数コストについては
すぐに戻るが、まず因数分解に関して
わかっていることを整理しよう。
先ほど数体篩について触れたが、これはコストのスケーリングという観点で現在最良の素因数分解アルゴリズムだ。
実のところ、このアルゴリズムのコストは厳密には証明されていない。数論のいくつかの未解決問題と関係しているからだ。
ただし、このような形のコストを持つと予想されている。
今回はbig-Oが指数部に入っているが、その細部には目をつぶっておこう。
重要な点は、試し割り法よりも大幅に優れているということだ。Nは確かに指数に現れるが、
1/3乗になっているため、コストははるかに低くなる。だからこそこのアルゴリズムは
RSA250のような数を扱えるが、試し割り法では到底無理だ。
それでも、Nのべき乗が指数に現れている意味では指数的なアルゴリズムであり、その結果として
RSA1024のような数はやはり扱えない。
では、多項式コストと指数コストについてもう少し詳しく説明しよう。
アルゴリズムのコストがNのB乗のbig-Oであるとき、多項式コストと呼ぶ。
Bは任意の正の数でいいが、重要なのはBが固定されていること、つまり
入力長nが大きくなっても変わらないということだ。
先ほど見た例、つまり整数の加算、乗算、除算、GCDの計算、モジュラー指数演算については、
Bが1、2、3のいずれかだった。
これらはすべて多項式コストのアルゴリズムだ。
ただし、一般的に多項式コストと言う場合、Bはどんな正の数でもよい。
100万でも構わないが、固定されていなければならない。
大まかな抽象化として、多項式コストのアルゴリズムは一般的に効率的なアルゴリズムとみなされる。
確かに単純化しすぎだが、大雑把な指針として、多項式コストのアルゴリズムは
問題の構造を何らかの形で利用して解を構築するものであり、総当たり的なアプローチとは対照的だと考えられる。
あるいは非常に広大な空間を網羅的に探索するアプローチとも異なる。
もちろん、長さNの入力に対してNの100万乗のコストがかかるアルゴリズムは、
合理的に効率的とは見なされないし、大きな入力で実行できるとも思えない。
それでも、Nの100万乗のアルゴリズムでさえ、何か巧妙なことをしているはずで、何らかの形で構造を反映している。
解くべき問題の構造を活かして、指数的なコストスケーリングを避けているのだ。その指数スケーリングは
広大な領域を網羅的に探索すれば避けられないものだ。
実際には、多項式コストアルゴリズムの発見は効率化への第一歩に過ぎない。
ある問題が重要で、誰かが初めての多項式コストアルゴリズムを発見したとする。指数がかなり大きくても、
アルゴリズム設計者たちがその指数を下げる改良を見つけることはほぼ確実だ。
本質的に、ある問題に対して多項式コストアルゴリズムが存在することは、その問題を解くことの実現可能性を示している。
ある程度大きな入力に対してもね。ただし、真の効率性に達するにはまだ多くの作業が必要かもしれない。
計算量理論では、アルゴリズムのコストが準指数的であるとは、コストがすべての正の実数epsilonに対して2のN
のepsilon乗のbig-Oであることを意味する。準指数的でなければ
指数的、あるいは2の2のN乗のような超指数的になりうる。それは二重指数と呼ばれる。
ただし、出力が超指数的な長さでない限り、どんな問題も実はBoolean circuit で
指数コストで計算できるというわけだ。したがって、ここでの重要な区別は多項式コストと指数コストの違いだ。
整数の素因数分解には、準指数コストの古典アルゴリズムは知られていない。
例えば、数体篩のコストは、epsilonが1/3以下の場合、2のNのepsilon乗のbig-Oではない。
だからこの定義を満たさない。
間違いなく非常に巧妙なアルゴリズムだが、それでも篩であり、実質的にはまだ探索している。
与えられた数の因数を特定するために非常に広大な空間を。
次のレッスンで見るように、整数の素因数分解には実は多項式コストの量子アルゴリズムが存在する。
Shorのアルゴリズムは多項式コストを持ち、具体的にはモジュラー指数演算と同様のqubitコストを持つ。
もう一つ、馴染みがあるかもしれない問題のクラスとして、NP完全問題がある。
このレッスンではNP完全問題について詳しく説明しないが、興味があれば調べてみてほしい。
これらの問題のどれも準指数コストを持たないと予想されている。
これは本質的に、指数時間仮説と呼ばれるもののcircuitベースのバージョンだが、今のところ誰も証明する方法を見つけられていない。
実際、NP完全問題に線形コストアルゴリズムが存在しないことさえ証明できていない。
少なくとも現時点では、これらの問題に対して将来的に信じられないほど独創的なアルゴリズムが発見される可能性を排除するのは本当に難しい。
多項式コストと指数コストの関係を
示す図がこれだ。
X軸は考えている問題への入力の長さで、Y軸はその問題を
解くコストを表してる。
もし好みなら、問題を解くのに
必要な時間として考えてもいい。
指数コストのアルゴリズムは
こんなふうにスケールするかもしれない。
短い入力の場合、たとえば12という数を素因数分解するようなとき、
コストはそれほど高くないかもしれない。
でも入力が長くなるにつれ、
コストはいずれ爆発的に増大する。
一方、多項式コストのアルゴリズムは
こんなスケールになるかもしれない。
一般に入力が長くなるにつれてコストは増加し、場合によっては指数コストの
アルゴリズムより高くなることもある。
でも最終的には指数コストのアルゴリズムより
ずっと安くなって、同じような極端な形では
爆発しない。
指数コストのアルゴリズムはそういうふうに
爆発するんだ。
払えるコストの上限、あるいは答えを
待てる時間の上限があると想像してみよう。
時間で考えるなら、指数コストのアルゴリズムが
使えるのは一定の長さまでの入力だけだ。
一方、一般に多項式コストのアルゴリズムなら、
より大きな入力でも問題を解ける。
だからたとえば、何千ビットもある数のGCDは
簡単に計算できるけど、最悪の場合は
そのサイズの数を素因数分解
することはできない。
レッスンの最後のパートでは、量子コンピュータ上で
古典計算を実装することに目を向けよう。
より具体的には、Boolean circuit で実行できる
計算はどれも量子 circuit でも実行できることを見ていく。
コストもほぼ同じだ。さらに、これをクリーンな方法で行うことができて、
これらの計算を実行したい場合に重要になる。
より大きな量子計算の中のサブルーティンとしてね。
議論が進んだらクリーンという意味を説明する。
このプロセスでは
Toffoli gate を使う。
Toffoli gate はcontrolled-controlled-NOT gate だと
覚えてるだろう。だから標準基底状態への作用は
画面で見えてるとおりだ。
Toffoli gate はAND関数の
query gate みたいなものとして考えられることも
注目してほしい。
それは文字通りの意味でquery gate だということじゃない。レッスンの最初に言ったとおり、
今はquery modelの中で作業してるわけじゃない。
むしろ、その作用がquery gate と
同じパターンに従うということだ。
2値AとBをAND関数への入力として考えられるし、
query gate みたいに
これらの値は出力の一部としてエコーされ、
関数の値、つまりAとBの論理ANDが
一番下の qubit にXORされる。さて、Toffoli gate は標準的な gate セットに含めていない。
気が変わることもできるけど、実はそうする必要はない。
なぜなら代わりに、Hadamard gate を使って
Toffoli gate を実装できるから。
TゲートとTダガーゲート、そして
ここで見えるようなcontrolled NOT gate を使うんだ。
この circuit が Toffoli gate を実装しているのは
全然明らかじゃないけど、実際にそうなんだ。
私の言葉を信じてもいいし
自分で全部計算して追加練習してもいいし、
Qiskit かPythonに聞いてもいい。
行列の積を計算できるソフトウェアなら
どれでも掛け算をやってくれる。
レッスンの教科書コンテンツで
Qiskit を使ってやってるのが見られる。
では、Boolean gate を量子 circuit でシミュレートする話に移ろう。
必要なのはNOT gate だけで
controlled NOT gate と
Toffoli gate だ。
これらの操作はユニタリーであることに加えて
全て決定論的で、こういった操作を可逆と表現することもある。実際、
可逆計算の研究は量子コンピューティングより前から
あって、この手順全体が実際にそこから来ている。
心配すべき Boolean gate は
NOT gate、Hadamard gate、FANOUTゲートだ。
これから示すのは、これらの gate を実装できる、
好みなら simulate できるということだ。NOT gate を使って
controlled NOT gate と
Toffoli gate でね。
明確にしておくと、欲しいのは
今言った Boolean gate の値を計算できる量子 circuit だ。
入力として標準基底状態の
qubit を与えたときにね。
任意の量子状態を入力した場合の作用は、
いつものように線形性で決まる。
NOT gate については特別なことは
何もしなくていい。NOT gate はNOT gate で、直接実装できる。
OR gate はToffoli gate と
NOT gate を使ってシミュレートできる。
AND gate は簡単だ。特に、Toffoli gate が本質的にAND関数の
query gate 実装だと
さっき言ったことを
踏まえるとね。
正確に言うと、ゼロ状態に初期化された
新しい qubit を導入して
その qubit を Toffoli gate の
ターゲットにして、2つの入力 qubit を
コントロールにする。
こういった余分な qubit にはいろんな名前が付けられてて、
量子計算によく導入される。
名前を一つ選んでworkspace qubit と呼ぶことにする。
workspace qubitについての一般的な前提は、最初はゼロ状態から始まるということで、多くの場合
使い終わったらゼロ状態に戻せる、でも常にそうとは限らない。
図では、点線の四角の中にcat zeroがあって、この qubit の
初期化がプロセスの一部であることを示している。こういう
新鮮な qubit がなければ、このシミュレーションはできない。
一番下の出力 qubit が重要なやつで、AND演算の結果がそこにあるから、
残りの二つはもう
箱の中に入れておいていい。
実際、この二つの qubit を消すのが
この AND gate をシミュレートする仕事の一部だとさえ考えられる。
まあ、片付けが必要なゴミみたいなもんだ。
ともかく、これが AND gate をシミュレートする方法だ。
AND gate のやり方がわかったから、今度はド・モルガンの法則の一つを使って OR gate もできる。
AND gate の二つの入力と出力に NOT gate を付けると OR gate になる、それだけのことだ。
最後は FANOUT で、これには controlled NOT gate と workspace qubit が一つあればいい。
具体的には、workspace qubit をターゲットにすれば、
入ってきた標準基底状態をそのままコピーできて、
それが FANOUT gate として機能する。
これで gate が全部揃った。
gate が全部揃ったから、circuit の話に移ろう。
Cというブール circuit があるとして、これは
AND か NOT と FANOUT gate で構成されていれば、どんなブール circuit でもいい。
Cの gate の数をTとして、Cが計算する関数にFという名前をつけよう。
FはここにあるようなNをCの入力ビット数として、
Mを出力ビット数、sigmaを二値アルファベットとする形をしていると考えられる。
やることはCの gate を一つずつ順番に処理するだけだ。
NOT gate はそのままにして、他のやつは今説明したシミュレーションに置き換える。
CがこんなふうになっていたとしたらRというcircuitがこんなふうに得られる。
この図では、シミュレーションに必要な workspace qubit を全部箱から取り出して下にまとめてある。
KはNOT gate以外のCのgate一つにつき一つ必要な、workspace qubit の合計数だ。
Rの出力は、Cの出力に対応する qubit で、ここでは上に描かれているが、
最終的には上にあるかどうかは実際には関係ない。
正確に言うと、任意のNビット文字列Xに対応する標準基底状態でRを実行したとして、
これらM個の出力 qubit はF(X)に対応する標準基底状態になる。
AND gate と OR gate から残った qubit も全部ある。
それらも処理しないといけなくて、全部まとめると何らかの標準基底状態になる。
その標準基底状態が何であれ、文字列Xの何らかの関数になるはずで、
その関数にGという名前をつける。
つまりGはCの gate によって決まる新しい関数で、
Rを実行した後にこれらの残った qubit がどんな状態にあるかを教えてくれる。
GはFの次の文字だから、この関数をGと呼ぶ理由の一つだが、
もう一つの理由はGがgarbageの略だからだ。
これらは全部 garbage qubit で、特に AND gate と OR gate それぞれに対して二つずつ garbage qubit がある。
必要な gate の総数はO(T)だ。
Cの各 gate に対して有界個の量子 gate が必要だからだ。
OR gate が一番コストが高い。それにはNOT gate が三つとToffoli gate が一つ必要で、
Toffoli gate は標準 gate セットから15個の gate を消費する。
つまりCの各 gate に対してRでは最大18個の gate になる。
最適化しようと思えばできるが、大まかな漸近解析の目的では、
RはO(T)個の gate を持つと単純に言っていい。
というわけで、元のブール circuit Cが計算していたのと同じ関数Fを
Cのサイズに対して線形なコストで計算できた。
この関数Fを計算することだけが目的なら、これで完成だ。
でも残念ながらこれらの garbage qubit があって、この circuit Rをサブルーティンとして使おうとすると、
量子アルゴリズムを動かす干渉パターンを
一般的に壊してしまう
より大きな量子アルゴリズムの中で使う場合に。
でも実際にはこのゴミを取り除くことができて、その方法はcircuit Rが逆転できるという事実を利用することだ。
言い換えれば、逆向きに
実行できるということだ。
これがどう機能するかを説明するために、まずRを実行し、次にRを逆向きに実行する場合を考えてみよう。
これはR†（Rダガー）として表せる。
明確に言うと、これはRの各gateを
逆の順序で適用し、
それぞれのgateの逆元を取ることを意味する。
NOTゲート、controlled NOTゲート、
Toffoliゲートはそれ自体が逆元なので、
これらのgateで考えるなら、
R†は単にRのgateを
逆の順序で並べたものに過ぎない。
ただし一般的には、任意のユニタリ量子circuitを今説明した方法で常に逆向きに実行できる。
つまり、gateを逆の順序で適用し、
それぞれのgateを
その逆元に置き換えるということだ。
これを実行すると、Rを実行してから
Rを逆向きに実行しても
何も変化しないとわかる。
つまり、ここにあるような標準基底状態から始めた場合、全く同じ標準基底状態で終わることになる。
もちろん、それだけでは
あまり役に立たないが、
余分なqubitをいくつか導入することができる。具体的には、
これはM個のqubitで、MはcircuitCの出力ビット数だ。
これらの追加qubitは任意の量子状態にできるが、仕組みを説明するために、標準基底状態にあると仮定しよう。
ある文字列Yに対応する状態だ。YはMビットの文字列で、できることは
ここに見えるようなcontrolled NOTゲートを
いくつか実行することだ。これにより、F(X)という文字列が実質的にXORされる。
下のMqubitsに格納された
文字列Yに対してだ。
計算全体の出力は
画面に表示されている通りだ。
XとYは任意の2値文字列だ。XはMビット、YもMビットで、K個のワークスペースqubitも必要だ。
Rを実行するとF(X)が計算され、
その文字列は上のMqubitsに格納されるが、
ゴミqubitも生じる。
そこで、出力F(X)を下のMqubitsにXORし、
Rを逆向きに実行して
ゴミを片付ける。
Rが決定論的であることが重要だと指摘しておくべきだろう。
上のMqubitsが標準基底状態の
重ね合わせにある場合、
これは正しく機能しない。
ただし、Rが決定論的な場合は
機能する。
今構築した量子circuitを元のブールcircuitCと比較すると、基本的に同じように
任意の関数に対する
query gateとして機能することがわかる。
違いがある。それは、全てを機能させるために
これらのワークスペースqubitが必要なことだが、
それ以外では実質的にquery gateを構築できている。
つまり、Cが計算する関数のための
query gateまたはquery circuitだ。
ちなみに、ワークスペースqubitを
初期状態に戻すことにも成功しているので、
原理的には再利用可能だ。
後続の計算のための
ワークスペースqubitとして使えるということだ。
必要であれば、量子circuit全体をQというボックスで囲むことができ、Cとの関係がより明確になる。
circuit QはCより一般的に大きくなる。CのgateごとにQにいくつかの量子gateが必要で、
中央のcontrolled NOTゲートも必要だが、
数はCのサイズに対して
線形のままだ。
また、これは任意のブールcircuitに対して機能する完全に一般的な手続きであり、Qを最適化しようとは全くしていないことも注目すべきだ。
特定のcircuitCに対しては、
Qのサイズを削減する方法が
十分あるかもしれず、それには手法の使用も含まれる。
必要なワークスペースqubitの数を
削減する方法もある。
それが求められるならば。そしてこれが
古典計算を
量子コンピュータで実行する手続きだ。
かなりシンプルだが、
できるようになることが重要だ。
特に、これができるようになった今、
量子計算の中で
任意の古典計算を自由に使える。
ただし、入力がエコーされ、出力がqubitの束にXORされるという、query gateの場合と同じ形式に従う必要がある。
ちょうどquery gateで行ったように。
コストは線形にスケールする。例えば、整数の加算といった問題のための量子circuitを作成できる。
乗算、除算、GCDの計算、モジュラー指数演算、これら全てをブールcircuitと同じ漸近コストで実行できる。
これにはワークスペースqubitが必要だが、少なくとも使い終わったら再利用可能だ。
最後に言及する価値のある補足として、この方法はquery gateを実装する手段を提供してくれる。
前のレッスンで示唆したことだ。
つまり、ある関数Fを入力として取るqueryアルゴリズムがあり、ブールcircuitでFを計算する方法があれば、
この手続きに従ってその関数のquery gateを構築し、queryアルゴリズムを実行できる。
それが有用かどうかはqueryの問題自体と目的によるが、本質的にこの構成は
queryモデルをより標準的な計算モデルに
接続する方法を提供してくれる。
これはある意味、整数の素因数分解のためのShorのアルゴリズムがどのように機能するかだ。
レッスンの前半で話した算術演算のいくつかを使って、
このようなquantum circuitを構築していく。
そうすることで、quantum circuitは
古典的な状態の重ね合わせに対してそれらの演算を評価する能力を持つようになる。
そして後で見るように、それによって整数を効率的に素因数分解できるようになる。
このレッスンはこれで終わりだ。主に標準的な非ブラックボックスの
計算フレームワークにおける量子アルゴリズムの基礎を
確立することに焦点を当ててきた。
基本的な数論に関連する問題という観点から、
主に計算コストについて話した。
計算タスクにおける多項式コストと指数コストについて論じ、
古典的な計算がどのように
ゴミなしのクリーンな方法でquantum circuitによって実装でき、
サブルーチンとして使用できるかを見た。
より大きな量子計算の内部で使えるということだ。
次のレッスンにもぜひ参加してほしい。Shorのアルゴリズムがこれらのアイデアをどう活用し、
多項式コストで整数を素因数分解できるかを見ていく。
それまでさようなら。